hey theo name's kaden uh
man i just got to get your thoughts on
on the vaping stuff man a couple of my
buddies have been hitting that sparky
nasty here for a while and they've been
they've been switched over to the jewel
or the vape whatever
and uh man i don't know what to think
about it man they just
keep trying to get me to hit on that
thing and man i don't know about hitting
on the toker man i got to get your
thoughts on it
holla back at me thank you brother all
right thank you so much there kaden and
uh
yeah cause jeweling is different people
do jeweling
you'll see somebody they gotta you know
hey you jewel
oh yeah just gargling vowels just
[Music]
when i was young jewel was a child
person's name
so somebody said you jewel i would be
like no i'm theo
who is she um
and now yeah the kids got everything you
know they got tiramisu flavored
watermelon bro
dog when i was doing you had to hit that
cigarette baby
like a damn man you had to stay in there
like a just a [ __ ] loose piece of
forest fire
just
you know what i'm saying you had this a
smoker had to smoke
there wasn't no secret yeah you know
this thing
also doubles as a hard drive you can
keep up like just like 60 jpegs on here
bro you do you jewel
and y'all got all kind of flavor they
got lasagna
they got everything man they got regular
mint they got cement
they got menthol peanut butter bruh
everything man
they got lactate somebody just hitting a
damn lactate jewel
say their bowels can't handle regular
jewel [ __ ] what
when i was young you had to smoke
and you had to risk getting busted
that's another thing about a jewel
i see people jeweling on the plane
i see people just juice blowing into
their pocket
blowing in into the dog's mouth they got
a little rescue dog on there with them
little schnauzer you know
they chimney and that [ __ ] up
when i was you know you had to smoke you
had to go hard
and you had to blow yet i blow it there
was no hiding that smoke
that [ __ ] was the industrial revolution
baby
i mean you look like a damn sawmill out
there just hitting winston's
and you smelled like it now somebody
comes in the house they're out there
they've been hitting that cherry or that
paprika
you know somebody comes in the house and
they've been hitting uh
the uh ricotta they just did 40 grams of
ricotta cheese jewel outside
it's just different man this [ __ ] is
weak now so i say put it down baby
put it down and pick up a real cigarette
pick up that real killer bruh
you know what i'm saying have some honor
get japanese with it pick
up a real cigarette and hit that bastard
cuz you out here hitting these fake dude
it can store up to like 30
jpegs in it
yeah man and it's peach cobbler flavored
[ __ ] i don't care
get that old dog i remember hitting a
marlboro red bruh made one of my eyes
closed for a month
i remember that [ __ ] was for real
and you had to come back to the table
smell you had to hide the smell
you over there rubbing gum all over you
in the garage trying to you spraying
double d
double d 40 on your buddy trying to get
the smoke off of him
everybody you and you come back to the
thanksgiving table smell like a damn oil
change
but you had to go through something now
you got people sucking out out here
sucking on a damn usb
port
dude my buddy's in the uh jewel uh he's
a professional
yeah he's in the semis in reno this
weekend
put it down y'all ain't doing [ __ ] bro
pick up a regular cigarette dude
smoke them for 20 30 years watch your
skin give in a little
and then go see the lord have some
respect for yourselves uh
so that's what i think of jewel man it's
hard to go off on that but i had to let
you know man
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been